right so I'd like to talk now about the
data science platform so following on
with our sort of cloud operations and
data science functionality so the data
science platform it's a platform it's a
cloud platform so I'm going to talk a
little bit just review i gave a talk
yesterday about Wolfram cloud I'm just
going to review some of the cloud
technologies again we think of these
platforms is very being very workflow
oriented taking a problem and helping
you to go through different steps to
solve it so I look at some some
workflows that we think are useful for
data science I look at some of the data
computation and data handling a
functionality that's that's in
Mathematica and then I'll look at how to
deploy and present results with with a
demonstration of all sorts of things so
the the data science platform I think of
it as a Wolfram cloud that is focused on
data science so it's going to harness
Wolfram engine Wolfram language
functions that have been a good for data
science and in the end that the data
science workflow we're going to think of
is a load data compute with data and
then deploy the the result so that's
that's one workflow but we also need to
think about other workflows for example
how do you how do you create you know
how do you create the computations or
the deployments so those are those are
workflows that we need to think about
Wolfram cloud quick quick recap so I
gave a talk on this yesterday yawn just
gave a nice talk some of the elements of
the cloud you have cloud CDF's cloud
notebooks exactly what yarn was showing
the the nice progress that have been
coming out on for this in the system
and we have the idea is there's a user
document lives in the cloud you can
share share work with with you the URL
in the browser there's no installation
and there's just one one version the
document and it can go to different
types of different types of devices it
just goes to browsers so it could be on
mobile for example again running when
you're running the code this is a way of
setting up cloud callable functions so
these might be functions that are
initiated by a user that's that's what
many of you think of you know you type
something into a notebook and you do
shift enter but there's all sorts of
other ways that are useful for running
things you might have things that run
according to a schedule you know every
day at midnight you want to process some
some data that was collected in the day
and then and then presented and these
are ways that our cloud is very much
focused upon supporting these these
other ways not just the interactive use
but these other ways of running running
Wolfram code so data loading so the the
all sorts of ways of loading data into
the cloud and again you might have what
we call a private cloud a personal cloud
and that will have access to to private
data then maybe the last things I didn't
talk about this yesterday but i'll i'll
be talking more about this today and
this is the idea of creating documents
under program control so what this means
is you're not you're not typing into the
notebook it's being created for you by a
program and we have a nice way to to to
to to provide this so let's think about
some some work flows that are relevant
for data science so we might think of a
data science workflow we might think of
a development workflow
and this this might take advantage of
some of the nice features of our cloud
technology so one is that our desktop
and our cloud versions integrate pretty
nicely so you might start out in a local
copy of Mathematica just sort of
prototyping working in a CDF a document
making some some computations
visualizations you might store this in
the cloud of course you could do the
same thing that you know usually could
do the same thing running running in the
cloud when you've made some progress
with your development then you might go
to a setup phase so this is where you're
taking your initial work and you're
going to set it up in the in the cloud
to run so you might store your code your
your notebook templates data functions
all sorts of things your store these in
the in the Wolfram cloud and you can do
that from a local copy of Mathematica or
from a cloud copy of mathematic loud
account and then you end up with the
sort of final result so this is really
what people are going to be working with
and this is the execution phase the
actual driving of the of the platform
and so you might have things like data
coming from a database you might be
reading from a database and then writing
back out to it you might be loading a
notebook template and then generating an
output report and then emailing results
out to people does there's all sorts of
possible ways of doing this and a really
key thing to remember here there's
really a key thing is that this is this
is a server operation there's no there's
no user driving this this is just
happening automatically in a server and
that's that's what makes it particularly
useful right
so let's keep going now so so the data
science platform is another of the
platforms that we're building from the
from our cloud technology and i'm just
going to log into this that's not so
encouraging now why is that you just
come in here it's in the second you
don't have to why not the problem is I
have to I have to log in first I should
have logged in before i started the talk
so when you login to passwords when
you're giving a talk you always have to
be careful you don't type your password
into the user field so i've seen people
seen people doing that and right so
there we go so that's now i can go back
and still not
I'm think I'm going to it's kind of
annoying I think it's changed right I
apologize because I think this says oh I
know maybe I'll try one last thing it's
possible that i need to the data it's
this is still an emerging technology and
that's just I'm not going to spend too
much time one last attempt there we go
it's this is this is not available II I
had to have my VPN connection setup
because it works so this is some some
idea of the the home page of the data
science platform that you might see now
essentially many of the functions that
driving this a Wolfram language
functions and their similar functions in
in all of these platforms what we've
done is we've optimized the user
interface for data science applications
and so for example on the front page
here we've got some some data workflows
set up so these things here are
particularly set up to support may be
uploading a data file or cancel or i'm
importing data from from a URL so you
would go through these to sort of get
started with your with your with your
work many of the elements are kind of
similar so there's like cows edf's api
functions and such like with with with
some new features that i'll be showing
you and just remember that everything
i'm showing you this is i'm showing you
the pride the public cloud but there's a
private cloud version
this as well so everything that works in
the public cloud works works in the
private cloud so that's some idea of the
sort of portal thing I'll get some more
demos but let's look at what Mathematica
actually provides for data science so
I'm just going to give some some some
demos and need to come back here and
nope and when this finishes running I
should have completed you're not quite
sure why it's taken quite so long to run
and good so I've got a data set here
some some data and it's it's just some
sample set of data that I made up with
Mathematica and I'm going to demonstrate
some of the machine learning features of
of Mathematica so it's it's a set of
heights and genders and I'm going to
make a picture here so I've got I'm
showing its this is the the male heights
and this is the sort of female heights
the there's like a distribution and the
men are slightly higher and I'm going to
use this this obviously a very simple
machine learning you know sort of
example and I'm going to train it on the
first 500 people and that builds this
classifier function and then if I feed
in a particular height it says that you
know 1.79 meters it thinks this is going
to be a a man and we can also get out
the the probabilities so that's quite
nice and then of course I could feed in
the feed get a probability just you know
plot the cumulative you know the
probabilities is that this would be a
cumulative probability of the
probabilities is a function of the the
height so that's the machine learning
we've seen other talks people have been
using this in much more sophisticated
ways doing image and text processing
this is a more simple use of the data
processing now another feature that was
added in in version 10
is the data set feature and this is a
nice way to handle structured data data
that has some sort of structure not
necessarily rectangular data and it
supports queries and computations and
such such like so it's a little a little
look at this so here I've got again a
data set that shows a number of data and
I've got to two columns so an age column
and and a height column and I can do
things like I can pick out the the first
element so I'm going to the first row
and I'm saying give me the height or i
could say pick out all of the rows give
me give me the height value so this is
kind of a one way to hold data now the
the nice thing about this is i can do
queries on it so i can do for example
show me all the rows with age greater
than than 25 and that pics pics pics
this out or i could select the the
reason i put the normal there is what
i'm going to do is select all the ages
greater than 25 and just show me the
height and normally this is going to
return this will also return a data set
so if i want the just the raw numbers
then I and enter it like this what's
this so that's that's just so that's the
you using the data set now I can also
apply a function to a whole data set or
a particular column so here I'm getting
the implying mean and it applies the
mean to the age column and the the
height column so that gives me the
things there or here I can get another
sort of nice aggregation of all the data
and I'm getting the making a plot or I
could put in putting things like you
know like like this and that's that's
that's that's pretty pretty convenient
way of working with data to sort of hold
it and make make make plots here's
another example this is you're using a
sort of you know another thing like it's
a database functionality I've got to two
tables of data and I want to sort of
combine them in a way so that I things
for which the this sort of ID column so
in it is equal so in SQL language this
would be a join and I can do this with
the join across with with the joint
across function so I apply that to the
two data sets and I say I want to
combine them for where the ID is is is
equal or I could then do that and then
sort by sort sort by the ID or I could
sort by the the floors so this is this
this is a nice way to work with with
data and do queries and and and and and
and handle them and this is something
that we're developing as more versions
come out and we'll be looking to build
special optimized versions and versions
where the data really is coming from an
SQL database or versions where the data
is very large and lives in a in a file
on your you know a sort of a file it's
not resident in in memory all at the
same time so that's data set another
system that we added in in in version 10
I think was a nice time series
functionality and so this is this is a
way of working with data that has a time
element to it and you know I've got a
nice basic sort of set of data these are
measurements of some some stock market
thing that over over over a few years
and I can do all sorts of you know nice
you know it knows about time so I could
do something where you know I
you know do some sort of smoothing so
I'm going to do calculate the mean mover
mean over 10 day periods and and it
takes care of you know if the data snot
you know sort of uniformly spaced and
things think things like that now one
things that's some nice things about
these time series some very basic things
that I very often see people when they
make when they use Mathematica like they
make they make plots of data you know
where one of the elements is time but
they don't you know the axes you know
they just put sort of you know integers
or something it's it's much more
powerful when you're making
visualizations to actually put you know
these these these are like yours so you
want to show that the years that they
represent so it's a very nice convenient
workflow for producing good good plots
like that and here's another useful
feature that you know I've seen people
and they write quite a lot of code and
what they have is they've got two
different data sets covering different
time periods and they want to combine
them in somewhere in some meaningful way
and so the time series set of functions
has a nice feature called time series
insert which is sort of joining the two
thing and making a composite time series
so I've gone you know this this one goes
from 2006 to the middle of 2008 and this
goes from 2008 through to 2015 and when
I do the insert operation it's it's it's
combine them in some sort of useful way
so these sorts of functionality is a
tremendous you know tremendously
powerful and will save you a lot of lot
of time and there's other useful
features in the time series set of
functions for rescaling and shifting
these really save you a lot of effort
and the time series in particular it's
it's very optimized so it's fast for
these operations and it's very efficient
at holding you're holding your data so
that's the time series computations I'm
not really going to give you a big demo
of this but we've been working over many
versions
mathematica to enhance the statistical
computation features so you can take
some data and you can extract various
information from it various statistical
distributions and we have a very
powerful statistics set of functions
that that is is really optimized and and
a large large set of functionality with
computations and then all sorts of
special plots and and so on and this
uses all sorts of other features of
Mathematica such as the the optimization
functionality to do parameter estimation
for example and this is something that a
lot of over the years a lot of users of
Mathematica have become particularly
interested in and the data science
platform is now making it able to use
these things in a wider set of in more
sort of ways now another data relevant
piece of functionality that we've added
is this thing that we call data drop so
this is built on top of our cloud so
you've seen people talking about api
functions and things like that so this
is a a data-centric data aggregation
service that we've added and it's based
upon these things that we call data bins
so I'm just loading a little data bin so
this is coming from the cloud so you set
up one of these bins and then you can
sort of add add data to it as as you go
along so this is really a time-series
aggregation of data so you sort of
adding data as as time goes goes along I
can see the all the values of the data
in the data bin and I could make a list
plot of them and then I could there are
things like data bin add if I wanted to
add more data to the data bin then this
is a web function so it's going off to
the to the cloud and now this data bin
has 51 elements
as already I must write right I've
already added that data point previously
but this is a pretty useful function for
working with data and there's all sorts
of ways of accessing this data so i can
go to the the web to the data drop
website and when this opens up its going
to give me some summary of this
particular set of data and i can work
with it in in wolfram alpha for example
and it's giving me some some sort of
information about it so you can work
with this in a bunch of different a
bunch of different ways so that's that's
that's data drop data drop also in
private clouds you can have a private
version of data drop okay now I want to
talk about report generation so we've
had data we've loaded data may be from
data drop we've done computation with it
now we want to produce some sort of
output summary of the information that
people could look at and and use and the
report generation is is a way that we've
developed so it's based upon template
notebooks so I'm going to let's come and
so I come and and I come and add various
little sort of add markup in the
and I'm going to do
so I've made a basic template like this
a quick way that's that's pretty handy
is does this sort of generate button
that's a quick preview type of thing but
I can also just come and execute the
report with this generate document
function I typing too quickly I didn't
finish close the there we go so let's
come and rerun this so then I would
prepare the data and then execute the
report and then I've created so this is
a way of creating a new notebook but
without having to sort of insert all
that all the details so we've got more
examples of this here's one that is
based upon a more elaborate one and this
is going to load some financial data so
this is a sample example that we have
and this is running its loading some
some financial data using our financial
data feeds that we have the basic
financial data system that we have and
so I've created a dynamic report output
here but what's nice about report
generation in Mathematica is this is a a
CDF so it's not like a static dead
document it's an interactive thing that
I can in that I can sort of you know
sort of work with in ways other ways
that I can work with CDF so and then
here's another example that I kind like
that Anthony put this together and so
this is his this is a way of closing the
gap on his a classifier so remember his
machine learning it had nice machine
learning example where he was processing
reviews on the amazon website and then
he built this little micro site here and
you can type in the ideas you type in a
the name of an actor and it runs the
thing and it creates so this is in the
browser and it's creating a cloud CDF
output with the that we see here and
this is a coming and seeing here what
what what we've put together here and
this is showing how his classifier
compares with the the actual reviews
that have been put together so this is
another sort of use of notebook notebook
templating but this is one that's
running in the web given the time
constraints I'm not going to spend all
my time wait wait wait for it to to
complete in the data science platform I
think that's useful is to take this
templating system and run it in you know
sitting in the data science platform and
here's another example that one one
might imagine where I take some a
template and then I'm going to inject
insert data in it to make some sort of
schedule for something so I can now come
and deploy this to the web so I'm
pushing the template up to the web and
I'm going to push the data up to the web
and now what I'm going to do is another
cloud deploy where I'm deploying a thing
we call the document generator the
document generator is a complete
workflow a complete wrapping of document
a template there's a driver to generate
the two to generate the data that's
going to be inserted into the document
and then some things like to set up a
notification and then I can run this
thing either now I set this to run when
when I'm asking it to run so I've set up
this run scheduled task
thing here and then if I come and look
at my email given the time constraints
I'm just going to show you what happens
is I get a email to me a report that
tells me that this this you know
computation has run in the cloud it
emails out the results and that's that's
that's that's a pretty nice workflow to
process data and utilize mathematical
computations in the in the web right we
can also take this obviously we can run
it on a time schedule and there's a UI
for setting up setting up the schedules
as well and the output of these
documents obviously cloud CDF's pretty
pretty appealing it's it's very easy to
send but we can convert into PDF or
static web pages and it's it's very
customizable so I'll just summarize and
then then we can end data science
platform it's a workflow it's designed
to optimize data science workflows
taking data science functions from the
Wolfram language it makes use of the
desktop cloud hybridization functions
that features that we have and it takes
advantage of a lot of cloud benefits
like zero configuration and suchlike but
we also get in a private cloud you could
get sort of privacy and scalability and
it's again very much focused on this
sort of execute workflow driven in the
cloud providing data processing using
data computation features of the Wolfram
language so thank you very much